until now millions of people only knew
Chanel Miller as Emily doe that's the
name she was given by the legal system
in 2015 Brock Turner sexually assaulted
her outside a Stanford fraternity party
while she was unconscious and
intoxicated the former champion swimmer
was convicted of three felony sex crimes
but the judge sentenced him to just six
months in jail citing his youth and lack
of criminal history
he served only 90 days behind bars and
is registered now as a sex offender for
life well this month
Chanel revealed her true identity to the
world on 60 minutes Sunday she shared
her name and face with the millions who
already knew her story
Chanel's new book is called know my name
a memoir it's out today we spoke with
her yesterday I'm very struck by the
title know my name why did you want us
to know your name I'm here to finally
exist as my full self for five years
I've had to compartmentalize my life and
it's begun to feel really fragmented so
this is the first time where I can exist
openly and speak openly and not have to
hide a single element of my life when
the verdict came in you would think you
would think that would be okay
I won yeah and now I can move on with my
life but that is not what happened to
you will you win and then suddenly
you're back in the present and you look
around you realize I don't have a job
I don't have anywhere to live my sister
feels broken my parents you're such a
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah you look around and
everything has been wrecked you don't
even know how to begin rebuilding your
life integrating yourself back into
daily life you fight so hard just to
survive it and emerge but when you get
there it's you feel empty you said at
one point you know I didn't want to be
damaged goods you know what I wanted yes
yeah but if anyone ever knew that I was
this body behind the dumpster they would
think I was just dirty or irresponsible
or reckless that I wasn't capable of
hand handling myself and that I should
just be embarrassed when really I've
learned that I'm extremely brave for
asserting myself I feel more confident I
feel capable I feel like anything I
encounter in the future I now have the
tools to handle them and I'm curious
about your advice for women who have
been assaulted what do you want women to
know about this process I think it's an
extremely brutal process and we need to
do more to fix it and make all of these
obstacles transparent know that if you
haven't reported you don't have to carry
that burden of oh I should have done
more I should have said more the system
was not set up for you to succeed it's
not a nourishing environment we need to
be working harder to create an
environment where survivors feel
comfortable being supported and knowing
that when they do some form of justice
can be attained they won't just be
completely demoralized and dehumanized
for an extended period of time now you
have a huge microscope on on you and I
think you will really be an example for
other women you know to hear somebody
say so concretely that okay I was drunk
but that is not okay what you did we all
know that yeah but many women or some
women in there in your position would
have said well I did kind of bring it on
myself maybe I shouldn't have gone to
the party maybe I shouldn't have had
that much to drink
yeah but exactly that you can say I can
say I shouldn't have had that much to
drink it's true boom done fixed right
but this problem of violence that's so
pervasive is still not fixed that we're
still allowing to happen fixating on
alcohol to me is so easy it's such an
easily excusable thing that we do to
blame the victim and it's so outdated
and I'm so sick of it there's violence
everywhere it's not just during these
parties it's when you're walking down
the street it's in the workplace it's in
the strawberry fields and you want me to
believe that oh it's the drunk they
who are bringing it on themselves drunk
or not this is what we endure as women
we do the labor of putting up with this
stuff every day of our lives we spend
our own energy trying to navigate our
life trying not to get assaulted trying
to be safe and I'm tired of fixing who I
have to be in hiding in order to make it
through the day I'm not going to work
this hard all the time just to keep
myself safe we deserve to live we
deserve to go out and have a drink with
our friends and walk down the street at
night we deserve to have a full life and
nobody is allowed to hurt you period
that is the baseline and I will not make
excuses around that sentence we have to
know that sentence nobody is allowed to
hurt you period what's been the reaction
from the 60 minutes piece really
wonderful I I just like every night I go
to sleep saying thank you like I just I
feel this immense gratitude like I began
in such an isolated and terrified place
and I really I didn't enjoy facing the
world in the morning and now like I feel
excited when I get up and I feel excited
when I show up and I get to meet all
these people it's like it's so enjoyable
for me mhm and like such a gift to be
able to experience something like this
in my little lifetime I've come out at
the other end of that spectrum of
emotion and I know it's gonna be
difficult and I know there's gonna be
challenges that are going to come but at
the moment I just feel this immense
Welling of gratitude well she is guys an
amazing amazing young woman and she said
the only time she can talk about the
story and the brutality of it and
humiliation you know in the isolation
that she felt she said I'm okay talking
about that and being composed she starts
to tear up when she thinks about how
kind people have been to her and
how supported she is the support she's
received that's what gets to her and the
thing that struck me about her she said
we wouldn't even have been here she
doesn't believe if he had just
apologized if he had just said look I'm
so sorry things got out of hand
I didn't mean you know I'm sorry that I
did that that I behaved that way
she said that's all I wanted him to do
was apologize and acknowledge that he
had done it she said we might not choose
it I don't want to be a public person in
this manner I never wanted it but it's
so great to see the strength she's found
from all of this and that she's getting
from people they didn't want to be a
public person but she's an extraordinary
human being and no drawer Denari
translator of her experience and as a
result that Judge was recalled actually
the one who sends ROC Turner just three
months in jail inaudible California
change to because of that because of her
case she's so eloquent about all this
she absolutely is for more of our
conversation wish you know we talked to
her for quite a while yesterday head
over to cBS This Morning Calm